bonjour à tous l'autre jour je tombais
sur une photo thomas p pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas thomas pasquet c'est un
astronaute ce qui a fait plusieurs
missions au sein de l' iss la station
spatiale internationale
et c'est au sein de cette station
spatiale tu prends des photos comme
celle ci
personnellement je trouve ça magnifique
et ça m'amène à me poser certaines
questions
pour tout vous dire mon activité
professionnelle ces psychologues et
psycho pédagogue
concrètement en activité ça consiste à
aider les étudiants à réussir leurs
études en les aidant à apprendre à
apprendre et à rester motivés pour leur
concours
quand je vois cette photo
ça me fait me poser cette question par
rapport à la motivation
comment des hommes comme thomas pesquet
sont-ils motivé a passé des années
entières de leur vie avoué des années
entières de leur vie à découvert de
l'espace
qu'est ce qui donne envie à thomas
pesquet allait littéralement passé des
mois entiers au sein de l' iss où sa
chambre fut même pas la taille de celle
d'harry potter
en plus être petit le loyer très cher
pour marquer la vie est belle mais bon
quand même quand je vois ça moi je me
demande d'où tient-il cette motivation
et mieux comment pourrait-on s'inspirer
ce qu'il fait pour être motivés pour
l'appliquer à d'autres sujets c'est ça
que j'ai envie de décortiquer danser
dicks et que je vous présenterai
aujourd'hui
en premier lieu quand on y réfléchit
c'est assez évident que ce soit à la
découverte de l'espace découverte de la
terre ou simplement la découverte de la
nature en face de chez nous
l'être humain est curieux et cette
curiosité ce besoin de comprendre les
choses veut l'amener à explorer plein de
choses
je veux dire cette curieuse idée qui a
amené à des aventuriers enfin qui a
amené des aventuriers à découvrir de
nouvelles terres fertiles c'est cette
curiosité qui a amené darwin a
révolutionné le monde de la biologie
cette curiosité qui vous a amené là bas
cette curiosité ce besoin de comprendre
les choses va amener les personnes à
être motivé pour en savoir plus
l'homme ne peut pas rester dans
l'incompréhension il veut comprendre
tout de suite et pour cela j'aimerais
vous donner un exemple une petite
histoire en posant en imposant notamment
une question
saviez vous que lorsque la lune est bien
évident en ciel les nuits d'hiver les
lacs gèlent mais lorsqu'on ne vois pas
bien la lune qu'elle est un peu
recouvert pas nuage est bien là les lacs
ne gèle pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui fait ce phénomène
est bien au moyen âge
on était persuadés que la lune et mettez
des ondes glacial et gelé le lac
plutôt bonne explication après tout
pourquoi pas
et bien cette explication est fausse
la réalité est que les nuages agissent
comme une couverture pour la terre
il la couvre et conserve la chaleur
accumulée de la journée et lui renvoie
et c'est cette absence de nuages qui
fait 7 dissipation de chaleur et donc là
les lacs gèlent
ce qui est intéressant c'est un exotisme
noter que même si les hommes du moyen
âge n'est pas les moyens de comprendre
la réalité physique du phénomène
ils n'ont pas voulu rester dans
l'incompréhension et ont tout de suite
inventé cette explication
cette curiosité nous motive à partir à
la quête de la connaissance pour
expliquer aux
hoquets
pensant cela parce que thomas pesquet
est il que ce qu'il écrit et bien oui
dans tout un tas de conférences et dans
tout un tas d'interviews de ma pesqué
pose tout un tas de questions au public
à son interlocuteur ou même à lui même
il se pose tout un tas de questions
ok est-ce que ça suffit je veux dire
je suis bien curieux de la couleur des
yeux de cette personne dans le public
n'empêche que je pas à s'avouer mallet
entière pour assouvir cette curiosité il
doit y avoir quelque chose en plus
c'est là où je repensais la conférence
ted à simon sinek comment les grands
leaders inspire l'action
dans cette conférence simon sinek avance
que pour parler à ce besoin de
comprendre les choses pour motiver
quelqu'un il faut lui parler en lui
expliquant pourquoi et pas comment
démonstration avec un exemple j'aimerais
vous raconter l'histoire de floyd un
cuisinier américain nous sommes en
pleine guerre en irak
et nous sommes à bagdad au sein du
pegasus une cantine militaire
savoir que les cantines militaires ont
très mauvaise réputation chez les
gourmets on y dit que la nourriture y
est fade et immonde et l'immunité un
profond
mais le pegasus avait une tout autre
image une toute autre réputation
on dit même que les soldats traverser
des zones dangereuses pour se rendre là
bas y manger là bas
qu'est ce qui fait cela après tout le
pays du sahel les mêmes matières
premières que les autres cantines
lorsqu'on demandait ali qu'est ce qu'il
y faisait et bien lui disais
je ne suis pas seulement responsable de
la nourriture je suis responsable du
moral des troupes
c'est là on peut noter quelque chose en
plus si on demandait à un cuisinier et
asus
comment il fait les choses et vous dirai
pas cela qui si vous demandez pourquoi
elle fait les choses il vous dira eh
bien je suis responsable du moral
troupes et là normalement il y en a un
des deux qui vous a un peu plus
incité la curiosité que l'autre si vous
avez un peu plus parler à antrim et
notre nature humaine qui ce besoin de
sens
ligne lorsqu'il ne se donne cette
mission d'être responsable du moral des
troupes
il va ajouter quelque chose il va
ajouter nouvelles saveurs et son travail
puisque cette mission veut lui donner la
motivation et l'engagement nécessaire à
la réalisation de travail c'est cette
mission qu'il va transférer ses employés
et c'est cette mission qui va rendre ses
employés plus motivés et plus engagé
bien plus que s'il leur avait juste
promet une promotion à la fin du mois
selon les chercheurs rien n'est si
cela pour cause que quand on donne une
raison satisfaisante à quelqu'un de
s'engager dans une activité la personne
s'engage beaucoup plus que celle qui n'a
pas eu cette raison
pour se motiver il faut savoir pourquoi
le faire
maintenant automatiquement
qu'est ce qu'il réponde quand on lui
demande qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est un
ami s
est bien thomas pesquet
lorsqu'on lui a posé cette question
disait on n'est pas juste là pour faire
de la recherche sinon personne ne
financeraient on n'est pas juste là pour
faire la conquête spatiale personne n'a
juste posé un drapeau sur une planète
non on est là pour faire bien plus que
ça ont pris les deux et tout cela n'est
qu'une étape pour aller sur mars
et c'est là on note quelque chose
d'encore mieux thomas pesquet en plus de
donner du sens à son travail se fixe un
objectif aller sur mars
dites-vous qu'il vienne conférence qui
date d'il ya six ans où il parlait déjà
de poser le pied sur mars qu'il parlait
déjà qu'il était parmi les premiers
volontaires y aller cela fait donc déjà
six ans qu'il à cet objectif en tête et
contrairement à floyd lee ont ils la
donner du sens à son travail à travers
le responsable du moral des troupes
il n'a pas donné d'objectifs
de rappeler ce qu'est un objectif aller
sur mars
pour parler d'une autre personnalité
elon musk le directeur de space x
c'est ce qui crée les fusées pour la
nasa
disait très souvent
qu'ils ne sont pas là pour
construire des fusées ils sont là pour
coloniser mars
cette même chose que font thomas pascal
rohn masque s'est fixé un objectif qui a
du sens pour eux et c'est en elle
chercherait à les aider si selon les
chercheurs l année d si la fiction
d'objectifs et hyper intéressante pour
se motiver d'autant plus et que ceux qui
se fixe des objectifs eux mêmes sont
plus motivés et engagés que ceux qui
n'en réalise pas tout cas ce que ceux
qui ne se fixe pas d'objectif
année d'ici notamment jeté une petite
anecdote en dix ans en parlant du
football qui a t'il d'amusant à mettre
des coups de pied dans un ballon si ce
n'est les objectifs qu'il ya derrière je
veux dire imaginez un terrain de foot y
aura les cages
c'est pas si le match serait tout aussi
intéressant
sachant cela que retenir de cette
conférence c'est quoi la clé la
motivation c'est être curieux vi et du
sens à son travail j'ai fixé des
objectifs
c'est déjà utile mais il ya bien plus
que ça la science de la motivation
regorge de tellement de possibilités
pour être motivé
j'aimerais donc vous présenter une
dernière expérience
cette dernière expérience de cordova et
le père en 96 ils ont appliqué le
travail d'une institutrice cette
institutrice faisait jouer à ses élèves
de primaire un jeu de découverte de
l'espace ou en fait il faisait des
fractions en mathématiques ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les fractions
intéressait pas
mais le jeu oui et c'est ce jeu de tir
couvert de l'espace qui a permis de
motiver et engager ses élèves
peut-être que thomas ps qui a fait
partie de cette promotion il juste
jamais cessé de jouer c'est une
possibilité
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il existe
tout un tas de possibilités pour motiver
et pour conclure je ferai juste un petit
résumé des points clés que j'ai abordés
dans cette conférence qui vous donneront
au moins quelques pistes non exhaustive
pour vous aider un peu du je l'espère en
tout cas vous serons
premiers points oui soyez curieux ne
restez pas dans votre bulle et si
toujours d'en savoir plus sonné comme un
aventurier mieux de partir à la
recherche de terres fertiles partez à la
recherche de la connaissance
c'est comme cela que vous allez vous
motivez vous engagez une fois que vous
êtes devenus curieux que vous poser
plein de questions donner du sens à
votre travail repensez à floyd lee est
ce que vous êtes là pour juste faire la
cuisine ou est-ce que vous êtes là pour
être responsable du moral des troupes
rappelez vous pourquoi vous le faites et
pas comme
une fois que vous êtes curieux que vous
donnez une chance à votre travail fixez
vous des objectifs
fixez vous des objectifs puisque une
fois que vous aurez de chance de votre
travail donnez vous un but à atteindre
repensez à thomas pesquet plus de six
ans qu'il a cette envie d'aller sur mars
plus de six ans qu'il a cette envie de
poser le pied sur mars son objectif
c'est un truc c'est un cap qu'il a
besoin atteindre et pour ça j'aimerais
que vous vous posez ces mêmes questions
quel est votre objectif quel est votre
destination à vous quel est votre
planète mars vous aura envie de
coloniser
j'espère que cette conférence vous aura
plu et je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté jusqu'au bout